If you grew up in an English
speaking country like me,
you probably heard multiple times by now
that English is the hardest language to
learn.
I for one,
believe this until I actually
looked at how other languages work,
and so in this video now we're going to
compare English to other languages to
see how hard it really is and see if truly
English is the hardest language ever.
Something to note though,
before we again obviously yes,
someone from like the Netherlands will
be able to learn English much easier than
someone from say China because something
like Dutch is much closer to English
then shiny. So we're going to look
at it from the point of view of Tom,
an alien who has never
communicated with language before.
Tom Has learned just about every human
language and existence and he's learned
just about everything there is to know
about the world by watching every one of
my freaking videos. So always prepared
now to make an appropriate analysis.
All right,
so proponents for the idea that English
is truly the hardest language to learn,
come at it with English is the
hardest because of its slaying.
Okay,
no offense.
But anyone who believes that English
is hard because of it's slang has never
studied another language.
Well,
let's just set this straight right now
just about every language has slaying of
some kind. Okay? So you could
retort to this with, oh,
but the British empire spread
his language all over the world,
creating a great variation
and die electing such things.
But Britain was not the only
country with a global empire.
The former lambs is Spain, Portugal,
France, the Arab empire, ex Cetera,
credit dialects,
which are much more varied than something
like American versus British English.
Furthermore,
dialects in something like Chinese can
be in comprehensible to speakers of other
dialects in Chinese.
So this argument doesn't work because
English is definitely not the king of
dialects and slang.
But what about when people dessert there?
Desert and the desert,
or when Buffalo, Buffalo,
Buffalo, Buffalo, Buffalo,
Buffalo, Buffalo, Buffalo.
Well, English can get pretty
hardcore with its homophones,
homonyms and homographs.
Especially when you get into things like
your in your there, they're in there,
which many native English speakers
don't seem to fully understand if for
whatever reason, but it's not the only
language with these types of things.
So in comparison to other languages,
homophones,
homonyms and homographs are
pretty much out of the question.
Even though English can get
kind of carried away with them.
So while English isn't the only
language with these things like homonyms
spelling English words is
comparatively a nightmare. Take A,
for example,
these words,
rough cough plow though thought through
and even lock their all pronounced
differently yet all spelled the
same. Furthermore, it really,
vowel sounds in English aren't set in
stone at all either vowels and diphthongs.
Can you pronounce it very differently
depending on the individual word.
Really when you look at it,
the only rule in spelling pronunciation
that seems to stick in English is I
before e except after c. Ha, just kidding.
Part of his vocabulary issue is because
English took a lot from other languages.
I'll make another video explaining
this more in the future.
But essentially English started out
as a dramatic language that changed
radically when the Vikings and then the
French conquered England, for example.
Sometimes the Anglo Saxons
had their sicknesses,
the vikings had illnesses
and the French had diseases.
And as these three languages kind
of merged to become modern English,
all of these words stuck
around from each language.
And we still have more
synonyms for these words.
And as time went on,
English went out and borrowed hundreds
of words from scores of other languages,
meaning English may indeed have a larger
vocabulary than many other languages.
And other strange part of English
is not a grammar issue technically,
but it is necessary to prevent
awkward speech adjective placement.
English speakers say a
big old towering tree,
not add towering old big tree.
It's not grammatically incorrect
to say the ladder at all,
but English speakers find the former
sue be less awkward and more natural.
So there are some things that
make English hard to learn.
But what about English then is easy
compared to other languages? Well,
like I'm not no gendered nouns,
sorry.
It's just all the languages I've learned
have gendered nouns that don't refer to
anything that has a biology.
What I mean to say is grammatically
speaking tables in French,
our female fields in Latin are male.
Windows and Irish are female
and girls and German are neuter.
It really makes you appreciate the fact
that gender in English is essentially
just based off biology.
Also,
English syntax or word order
is very strict and unchanging.
This is a good thing in Latin Russian
check Greek Arabic to some degree.
For example,
they don't rely as much on word order
and instead change the endings of words
themselves slightly or inflect the
words in order to structure sentences.
English comparatively relies almost
entirely on word order and therefore
worrying about databse objects,
adjectives, normatives,
et cetera isn't as big of a deal
and English as other languages.
Looking more at grammar,
English verb conjugation is basically
pretty straight forward except in the past
and perfect tenses which can
get confusing and irregular.
Exemplary Grotzia teachers taught,
but preachers haven't prot they
preached other than that English verb
conjugation again is simple being uniform
except an adding an s in the third
person singular. So here we
have it. Essentially Tom,
the alien finds that English compared
to all other languages is certainly hard
in terms of spelling,
pronouncing these spellings.
English has a large vocabulary
and some other aspects,
but easy and several other aspects.
Namely no gendered nouns
which have no biological sex.
The straight forward syntax and a
simple verb conjugation pattern.
Some concepts you need to English like
the fact that additives don't agree with
their nouns and something like number can
be viewed as either difficult or easy.
Many other aspects which seem difficult
in English are similar in other
languages have not more difficult.
So in conclusion,
English is unique,
but most people would probably not find
it to be the hardest language to learn
relative to all the world's languages.
In fact,
it's not really that hard. It's just,
you know, it's just something you'd do.
You now you say your own native language
is the hardest language to learn.
I've heard the French say it.
I've heard the Germans say,
the Chinese say the Japanese say it.
Everybody thinks their own language is
the hardest language to learn. Well,
that's all for this video.
For more videos like these and much more,
you can check out the rest of fire
of learning. Thank you for watching.